welcome back to wings nen training and
today we'll be focusing on Gil now
basically what this involves is
condensing your aura around your eyes
like Sur which has the effect of
allowing you to see known constructs now
I want you to give it a go
focus your aura around your eyes and
tell me what it is you see what's that
an n subscribe button for the new ultra
view the activation of which would send
regular hunt hunt content straight into
your YouTube feeds hmm interesting oh
well I suppose you may as well use your
aura to press it then hello and welcome
to the new world review your source for
everything anime and manga and more
specifically welcome to the hunter
hunter Ark review where today we are
going to be taking another chronological
step forward in the series by examining
the heavens arena Ark Evans arena is the
third arc in the series consisting of
twenty manga chapters and eight anime
episodes of the 1999 adaptation while
the 2011 series played these events out
over ten episodes primarily contained
within the world's greatest combat
hotspot and so right off the bat I would
designate heavens arena as the Ark that
got me properly invested into an tanta
the hunter exam you know it was alright
and zoldak family Ark also happened and
it was okay but this is where things
really start to kick into gear because
Heaven's Arena introduces so many
concepts that would go on to form the
core features of hunt hunt going forward
namely being the shear unbreakable bond
of Gon and Killua as well as everything
to do with nen in regards to the formula
just before we get bogged down in in
discussion yes it was clear that gone
and kilowatt under strong friendship
pretty much from the moment they met
during the hunter exam but at the same
time it was never focused on like it
began to be featured in Heaven's Arena
because the series prior to this was
really playing up that group dynamic
between Corral pika leh Oreo gon and
killua
and the sock begins by dispelling that
dynamic never to be seen in Hunter
hunter again mind you and while this is
a shame in some ways it also opens the
door to greatness awaiting us and having
this time to focus exclusively on gon
and killua developing the world's
greatest friendship is very much
appreciated especially from the
perspective of kilowatt because go on
has clear purpose in Heaven's Arena
which is to get stronger so that he can
face Hisoka and return the insult given
to him during the hunter exam but rarely
kill his purpose at heavens arena is
just to support his first and best
friend I mean yeah you can argue that it
also does of the practical goal to earn
money and such and of course learning
nen does become a big driving factor but
ultimately what keeps
kahlúa in this arc is his support for
gone I mean he even refuses to continue
his nen training until God is ready to
restart his it's a really beautiful
display and a great beginning the far
more dramatic events to come in future
arcs that result from Killers role in
the story going forward just on gone
though heavens arena also begins to make
him truly stand out as a Chernin
protagonist because I would say that his
betrayal in the hunter examined the
zoldak family arcs made him out to be
quite the standard you know cookie
cutter like figure it was a classic dumb
optimist innocent and pure and overly
concerned with his friends heavens Arena
begins to twist this impression quite a
bit and reveals the beginning of a very
selfish and even corruptible side to go
on a primary example of this would be
his recklessness and disregard for wings
rules when he signs up for a match
against Aikido which could have
potentially let his death and it's
really interesting because when I was
seeing this for the first time it didn't
feel all that off but in retrospect this
really is planting the seed for Khan's
eventual downfall because the thing is
gone had no reason to fight Kido
initially a pot from pio selfishness and
lust for battle and I have a hard time
coming up with many other Chernin
protagonists who would have done
something like this you know
deliberately disobeying a teacher their
respect for the pure thrill of combat
and I don't mean that as a criticism of
gone either in fact it actually makes me
enjoy his character far far more because
at this point he is starting to break
the mold of a protagonist and
demonstrate an incredible flaw whereby
at times he will be completely
recklessly driven by his base desires
thus clouding his judgment and lore
often than not leading him into ruin now
in terms of heavens Arena itself this is
one of the more exciting locations that
has ever been involved in Hunter hunter
for me anyway and that's because I
really am a sucker for anything you know
tournament style involving layers of
progression and increasing challenge so
it really was a bit of a thrill to have
these characters set in that sort of
context even though both gone and kill
will make it very clear early on that
heavens arena itself is really of no
interest to them can you know sometimes
I do look back on this location and I
think wow there was so much left to
explore like learning the floor masters
but I was also said to be an event right
at the pinnacle of the tower known as
battle Olympia a festival of combat only
accessible to those who have earned the
right to be there through heavens arena
and in any other series this would have
been the goal of the arc or a long-term
goal to continue working towards for the
series kind of like the World Martial
Arts Tournament and Dragon Ball however
I do love that Takashi went to the
trouble of Korea
eating the intrigue the defend you like
this could develop and then he just
decided to cost it all away because this
story is not a traditional Shonen and
it's a powerful statement from Takashi
that he has decided that this series is
from here on out going to be its own
unique existence and there's a fair bit
of nice misdirection that gets laid out
in Heaven's arena like another example I
can think of his guns first fight
against Kido there's a chapter that ends
very stereotypically with gun engaging
in insanity and activating zetsu bus
leaving himself defenseless against Kido
spinning tops but being able to have an
enhanced sense of them as a result and
it really does look like this decision
is going to lead to him taking Kido down
but then when the very next chapter
begins it does so with kill we're
listing all of the bones have gone had
broken which was both a nice piece of
comedy as well as yet another jolt that
hunter hunter as a whole is not going to
play out as one would necessarily expect
and all right I think we've gone long
enough without delving into this but the
main feature of the entire heavens arena
rock is the introduction of the series
power system being men now when I was
first going through things I found them
to be quite a bombardment of information
because it's not a simple system at all
even at its most basic levels and they
don't think that people's understanding
of men is helped by the fact that it was
deliberately sort of miss explained by
wing before he decided to take gone and
kill her on board as his pupils so it
really was a lot to take in and there
are periods in Heaven's arena of lengthy
exposition all of which you really need
to be paying the utmost of attention to
because it forms the foundation of the
series going forward so it's not
something you can just comfortably skim
through which might not appeal to some
because it's the first example of that
times hunt onto ceasing to be a fun
adventure series and turning into more
of a lecture which can happen quite
often on a wide variety of topics but I
do appreciate these foundations much
more in retrospect because I know what
Takashi would come to build from them it
also probably doesn't help though that
heavens arena is certainly the most
boring use of men that we would see in
the series going forward because
actually you know what I would equate
the sock to heavens arena is kind of
like the tutorial level of a game where
it's trying to teach you its mechanics
in easily digestible stages and then
have you apply them to mock fights
before sending you out into the big wide
world to build on it then can feel a bit
like that at times and it also doesn't
even really begin to showcase the
crowning feature of the power system
which is the incredible diversity of
heart-to- available to its users also
known more commonly has a known
abilities and yes there are a couple
being hisoka's famous Bungie
we'll see his texture surprise and
Castro's doppelganger as well as his
Tigerfest ability so there is a little
taste of something something but in my
mind nan really does not take off until
York a new city begins and we start to
learn about the maddening ways in which
it can be implemented through various
combinations conditions and of course
the introduction of specialists although
I do think that heaven Sarina introduced
the concept in a very cool way by
showcasing increasingly more powerful
versions of Ren but the first one coming
from Zhu Shi then winged and then an
overpowering bloodlust effects from
ahsoka himself but the addition of nan
in Heaven's arena was an incredibly
welcome development to the series
because it gave gone a path forward
something to constantly work towards as
well as use as a narrative device to
allow a boy with a fishing rod to take
on stronger and stronger opponents and
speaking of one of said opponents would
be Hisoka and their match here in my
opinion is one of the crowning moments
of the entire series especially in the
2011 anime adaptation everything behind
this fight was incredible and I think a
lot of that is down to the motivation
behind it like dawn was not involved in
this battle to progress further and
further up the tower nor was he Sokka
they were both exactly where they wanted
to be and Gonz primary purpose was to
meet he soaked his challenge and punch
him in the face which he did and it was
glorious and so as much as Gaughan was
technically the loser of the match I do
consider this moment to be his victory
and the fact that such a thing could be
narrative Lee pulled off without
actually defeating Hisoka is a huge
credit to Takashi as a writer what I
will say though is that he soco's
ominous words are a bit sad in
retrospect dictating that the next time
they fight it would be to the death but
she is well that ultimate matchup seems
incredibly unlikely to happen these days
so that's kind of a shame because this
really is where the gun he saw a rivalry
would reach its peak but also I guess
where it would come to an end although
there are some positives to that because
it does allow Hisoka to go on and do
more interesting things some of which
actually include teaming up with gone so
that's just the nature of hunter hunter
really to briefly discuss the other two
major characters introduced during the
arc though wing and zhu xi i love them
both i think that zhu xi was a really
intriguing way to highlight the mystery
of nen during his match with kill allah
you know just the fact that killa was
superior to zhu xi in every way yet
completely incapable of knocking him out
it was also just a cool kid in general
which is exceedingly rare in any medium
because usually any child characters
the protagonist just annoying as hell
but sushi is actually quite inspiring
because he just works and works and
works plus he had some nice moments of
comedy to balance him out as for Wang
he's very much the same something of a
standard sense a character with some
core quirks but an always captivating
presence because his appearance is so
disarming looking like a super irregular
dude bruh but then being capable of
pulling incredible power of nowhere and
I really do wish we got to see more of
wing in the series in general so it is
always nice to revisit him in Heaven's
arena most of the other characters in
the arc I can give or take there I mean
the three primary antagonists if you
want to call them that bengi dose RSO
and revolt they're all pretty men but at
the same time that's exactly what they
were designed to be these broken shells
of humanity who made it to the 204 and
were violently initiated into the art of
nen plus I guess you could make the
argument that he Sokka did serve as the
ultimate antagonist in the end anyway so
the flatness of these three can be
forgiven but all around Heaven's Arena
resulted in a huge boost of interest in
Hunter hunter for me after this I
eagerly devoured the series until
reaching a on a certain roadblock which
we'll get to
but this arc really is what I would call
the beginning of peak onto hunter and
that pretty much does it for this review
of the heavens arena rock if you enjoyed
this video and the content that's
channel produced in general then please
do consider donating to the new ultra
via patreon because the support of all
of your amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video with like
share or subscribe because it also helps
both this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join fun at any
time and please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
Chenier takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on the heavens arena rock this
has been the new world review and I'll
see you next time
I don't want to ask you a question you
asked me a question oh well that's
that's not really how question corner is
meant to work but all right so my
question is as follows Jing and Li Oreo
are both in love with the same woman an
attractive girl whose name is say Minji
unfortunately
Jing had to take a trip to the dock
content that would last a week but
before leaving he gave men'she seven
apples and my question is why did Jing
do this please leave your answer in the
comments below